who knows kathy anyone know kathy at
home yeah kathy is the governor of new
york
and i don't know let's start with that
kai you you ready on that we're gonna
i'm gonna come to you in a second but i
just want to tee this up so
oh where do i begin new york the
dystopian nightmare
crime just through the roof
walk around you know you're like oh let
me go to the atm hopefully i don't get
held up today that's a horrible thing to
say but it's true actually i know a
couple people that were held up in atms
in new york city recently um robberies
thefts
mandates at least everyone got their
vaccine though right at least everyone
had their mask on
unbelievable
so we're going to start with um
governor kathy hokel actually put a gun
control package i don't know if you saw
this through this week pretty sweeping
we're not going to dig in on guns today
because i want to bring a gun expert on
and we're going to talk guns we're going
to talk too away we're going to you're
not going to want to miss that one but
i do have to give you um
one line that kathy said that was
fascinating um kai can you tee that up
for us yup i have it here
so let's see here
and in the state of new york
we're now requiring social media
networks to monitor and report
hateful conduct on their platforms thank
you senator anna kaplan and thank you
assign member patricia fahey
okay so
that's fascinating oh look i'm echoing
that's nice
i always i told them before the show i
said guys you know i don't have
headphones on and the one bad thing
about that is i don't get to hear that
sexy voice you know how you get sexy
voice when you have headphones on kai
nose that's why kai has the headphones
he wants to be sexy only he was like i'm
coming in hot to be a long reason i'm
coming in hot kai wasn't messing around
but i just heard it there for a second
and i have to thank you i put a little
kick in my step anyway um so you heard
that this is a gun control package but
they threw something a little a little
sweet extra nugget in there from new
york that the bill would require
social media networks
to provide a clear and concise policy
regarding how they would respond to
incidents of hateful conduct on their
platform this is coming in from forbes
by the way that i'm reading from
so you look at that and you say to
yourself hmm hateful contact
we can all get behind that's bad right
well that depends on what you're talking
about as hateful now do you trust
kathy hokel to make that assessment do
you trust her to make an assessment of
what's hateful and what's not the woman
who vilified everyone who didn't want to
get an experimental vaccine in new york
you trust her to decide what's hateful
you trust the social media companies
that vilified everybody who decided that
they wanted to
report back with some facts
about the vaccine when it came out the
covenant vaccine do you trust that let
me remind you of a little something i
went on the view earlier this year and i
was labeled as misinformation
hateful conduct is there does that
quickly become part of the
misinformation oh you're misinformation
you're hateful
you know does that suddenly become you
are you hateful because you disagree
with the wrong person or you disagree
with the narrative that big tech likes
or that big government likes or that
the left likes
because the left controls these
institutions
you know
ask yourself that you know i was labeled
as misinformation when i hopped on there
for repeating what the cdc had said
which was simply that you can get
covered um whether you're vaccinated or
you're not if you're vaccinated you can
still get and spread the disease the cdc
had already said that i was repeating it
but i was labeled misinformation because
it was an inconvenient truth and it
didn't fit the narrative
that abc one out wanted out there or
that people on that show wanted out
there
so i ask you are you comfortable with
something like that
does that give you pause hateful conduct
what does that look like what does that
mean who gets to define it
there's another cute nugget in here also
from kathy clueless kathy um
guns she says this
you know you have to laugh
new york already has some of the
toughest gun laws in the country but
clearly we need to make them even
stronger she says
so kathy is wondering why
the crime is going up in new york
despite some some really strong gun laws
now i said we weren't going to get into
guns here
but maybe kathy should consider fixing
the criminal justice system maybe she
should consider that it might be a
problem that criminals get out of jail
in new york they have almost no
consequence and then they're back on the
streets pretty quickly oftentimes maybe
she should consider the fact that the
police force has felt completely
unsupported
for the last x amount of years since
really the giuliani years truthfully
maybe she should think about what bill
de blasio did to the city and i know
kathy we're dealing with the governor so
it's the whole state i'm focusing on new
york city though because new york city
is the biggest problem there it's the
biggest problem there's a huge
distinction i don't know how much you
know about new york you go upstate it's
like a different planet new york city is
a bubble that is a problem for the state
when it comes to crime when it comes to
pretty much everything and i always
listen to people who talk about gun
control it's always fascinating to me
i wonder i mean does kathy think that
think about it criminal at home sitting
home says tomorrow i'm going to go and
i'm going to
i'm going to hold up an atm but first i
need to make sure i follow all the
proper steps of how to get a gun i want
to make sure i do it all right kai i
want to make sure you know i don't want
to break any rules before i go in that'd
be too much right i mean that's that's
just not what's happening right that's
not how criminals how people who intend
to cause harm think they're not worried
about
following gun laws
right
so people who follow gun laws are people
who are responsible citizens so kathy's
missing a few you know that's why i call
her clueless kathy
but i want to get back to that hate that
hateful language
um
be wary of anyone using using stuff like
that you know we're gonna stop
misinformation
what's misinformation who decides we're
gonna stop hateful language what's
hateful
is it it's just stuff that incites
violence is it stuff you don't like is
it stuff that just makes you
uncomfortable think about all the safe
spaces in schools now
it's just about what makes you
uncomfortable so a kid's in a class and
here's opinion he doesn't like and he's
like i'm uncomfortable that's that's
violent language may not be violent may
not be hateful may just be something he
doesn't like
so there is a a very big slippery slope
i also have a question in terms of this
is
when when i talk to my friends a lot of
what i can say could be considered very
hateful now i mean it in a sarcastic way
and when we're joking and we're having
fun but how is some
somebody monitoring that and being able
to be like oh that's hateful or that's
not hateful i mean i can say something
and be like wow that's like what is
going on here and it and just if you
read the words it could be considered
very hateful but obviously in a
sarcastic tone or they'd know my
personality they know that i'm just
joking or something like that right it's
subjective it's not entirely unless it's
like i'm going to come kill you
okay that's not something even in that
case right you sent me a meme and i'm
like jenna you're killing me right like
is that hateful now like are you
actually kidding me and you bring up a
great point and that that is the point
really because this isn't about hateful
speech this isn't about misinformation i
mean a talking point went out
misinformation use that all these people
challenging what you're saying yeah just
misinformation label them misinformation
people were de-platformed people lost
their jobs people you know i mean this
this is this is being used to destroy
people's lives so my question is i don't
know where this is going but i surmise
that hateful
is going to be quite broad and that it
will be used as a political tool
especially in a place like new york
against political opponents before you
can blink if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]